c'est dans une publication de mediapart
qu'apparaît le nom de simon au genre
joseph l'auteur de cet article pose une
question qui a alerté la justice dans
cette affaire deux carrés nantis
l'article évoque alors une rumeur qui
court avec insistance en martinique
simon jean-joseph le patron de la marina
je cite ne serait pas étranger à cette
affaire car il avait déposé un dossier
technique pour l'aménagement de la
marina du marin un équipement dont il
est actionnaire
son dossier je cite toujours a été
retoqué par la mairie du marais une
affaire qui s'est soldée pour l'instant
par quatre mises en examen dont celle du
maire du marin et par le placement en
détention provisoire du chef
d'entreprise jean louis de l'uci de fos
a revu depuis le 20 septembre dernier
il est mis en examen pour recel d'abus
de biens sociaux et complicité de
travail dissimulé
en décembre 2010 est il expliqué l'un de
ses projets à la ministre de l'outre-mer
cette extension de la maison de créer
sexe emplois nouveaux incluant une zone
de déconstruction des bateaux encore en
usage et enfin c'est un tic rappelle que
cette histoire politico judiciaire a
débuté à cause du ponton flottant
appartenant à la société car angie est
destiné à accueillir des bateaux des
pontons installer en toute illégalité
cet article qui ne prouve pas que simon
jean-joseph soit la ou l'une des
personnes qui auraient alerté la justice
suscite de nombreuses réflexions et
réactions en martinique